So this compare and swap instruction is going
to return true if it found that L and
me, that first two arguments, are the same and
therefore it set L to the third argument, in
that case, it's a success and success is
indicated by a true being returned by the operation.
But on the other hand, if the comparison failed,
it won't do the swap. It'll simply return false.
So it won't do the swap, but it'll return
false. So that's the semantic of this particular instruction. Again,
this is an atomic instruction. And this atomic instruction
maybe available in the architecture. But if it isn't, then
you have to simulate it using test and set
instruction. So in this particular example that I am showing
you, when I try to do this unlock operation
because this new guy has come in and he's executing,
he's halfway through executing his lock algorithm. So he has done
the fetch and store and, and he's going to set up the
list so that my next pointer will point to him. So
that's the process that he's in right now. So at that
point, I'm coming in, I'm saying, well, I want to do
the unlock operation, and that's when I found that my next
pointer is nil. And so what I have to do is,
do this compare and swap, and at the compare and swap,
now it's going to return to me false, indicating that
this particular operation failed. So once I know that this
operation has failed, then I'm going to spin. And so
the semantic of the unlock call is, I come in,
remove myself from L. And in order to do
that, I'm going to do this compare and swap on the
linked list. And if I find that the compare and
swap instruction fails, I'm going to spin. Now what am I
spinning on? When will it become not nil? So basically
what I'm going to do is I'm going to spin on
my next pointer, being not nil. So right now it's
nil. That's the reason that I think that there's nobody
after me. I was going to set this guy to nil.
But I know that compare and swap fail and therefore
I know that there's a request information and I'm going to
spin waiting for my next pointer to become not nil.
Now when will my next pointer become not nill? Remember
that this guy the new guy that is doing this
lock operations doing exactly what I did earlier. Right? And,
and what he's doing is he's gotten my coordinates and
he is in the process of setting it up, so
that my next pointer's going to point to him. So, eventually,
he'll complete that operation. So my spinning is on this
becoming not nil and it'll become not nil because of this
new guy completing what he needs to do as
part of this, lock operation. And, so, eventually the
next pointer in, in my note will point to him and at that point I can come out
of my spin loop. Now, I'm ready to signal
the successor that hey, you got the lock. So,
that's how I can make sure that when we
unlock the corner case that occurs during unlock and that
is there is no requesters after me, I can take
care of that by doing this atomic and ensuring that
there's no race condition between me the unlocker and a
new requester that is in the process of forming through this
lock call. So once this lock data structure has been
fixed up nicely by this new requester, so far as
I'm concerned, everything is good. I can, the list is
good, and therefore I can go ahead and signal the next
guy that he's got the lock and be done with it.